*Markimoo noises*
Ah, fucking fuck..
*singiplier* Hello everybody! Now,
we are back in this fucking game!
I hate it so much, never beat it,
tried for hours, and died again!
Fucking hell, oh fucking shit!
Here we go again, you bitch! *singiplier stops*
Okay, so welcome back to 60 Seconds.
I know it's been a long time,
but there has been an update to this game.
And NO!!! I haven't beaten it!
I know, I haven't. I never have.
I can't. It's fucking impossible. *we believe in you Mark*
*calmer* There's been an update. Now there are challenge modes,
which are super cool! I think..
I have no idea if they're actually cool or not.
But I'm gonna find out very soon, so!
With that being said, and now that the music
has gotten out of the way, the really loud music,
*calming breath*
We're gonna try one of these challenges.
How about the holidays? "Collect items and family
members listed below and make your way to the
shelter before time runs out."
Sooo this is easy! Oh! I'll get a haattt?!
All I need is a map? Oh!
I need a map, a suitcase, all my family members,
and then... that's it?
Well, that's EASY!
That's fucking easy! (sure it is mark)  Let's do this shit.
Do I even have to survive? No? Great!
I know it's been a while, and I've had
such, like, THEEEE toughest- howboutchu?
Ca-can I... what?
Oh, there we go. I was like, "What the fucking fuck?"
All right. *Markimoo noises*
Come with me, family. We've got places to go.
Heeeblagh.
Okay, so we just need the map and the suitcase.
Fuck, where are they? *struggle iplier*
Soup, water, soup, water... not that!
I didn't need four of those...
Okay... where the fuck is it?
Okay, suitcase, there it is. Hoobie doobie doobie doobie doo.
Bubbadee boo. Okay, where's the map, where's the map, where's the map?
I'M A MAP, I'M A MAP, I'M A MAP, I'M A FUCKING MAP,
where's the fucking map? There it is it's on the other side!
*screams twice*
Whoo! *Markimoo noises*
Bam! Done! Whoo!
Okay, that challenge was easy enough. That's not bad, that's not bad.
That's not bad, I got that. That's not bad.
Wait, do I gotta survive on this one or am I actually going on a holiday?
Do I have to survive?!
Heeeyyy! The end apparently. Yay!
Whoo!
Oh, no. Ohohohoh? Oh.
I won! I actually won! *mumbles* I didn't win,
that doesn't count, that's a bunch of bullshit. *voice intensifies* I didn't win.
Well, that was fun. I got a hat out of it, I think.
A'ight, so, Honeymoon. "Collect items and make your way to the shelter..." Ohh.
I'll get a beach hat. Ohohohoho...
I know these challenges aren't the same as everything that I
actually need, but... I wanna know
what I'm doing. Okay, so I'm going on an epic honeymoon
with my wife...
I'm not gonna remember all that, am I?
OH, I'm not gonna remember that.
Oh, boy, I am not.
Oh good! I don't need to remember all that. It's just listed right there.
Fire axe, don't need that, don't know why I got that.
A lock, need that to lock the door so the kids don't go anywhere.
Eeerrgghh!
Okay, alright, okay. Let's get these, these, these,
these playing cards, these... diddly diddly diddly viagra, these-
Oooh shit, cutting it close here, cutting it close, cutting it close...
Where is this stuff? Nope, don't need the kids.
Definitely don't need the kids.
Oh boy, where's the fucking stuuufff?!
Oh no, I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead.
We're all gonna blow up!
FUUUCCKKK!
Where is it?!
What the fuck?! Nope! Ooohh, bitch! Welp.
Weeelll I'm dead. No honeymoon for me and the honey, it's just gonna be horrible.
Yeah, I know, I-I've seen that a lo- oooh.
Delores is down there... ALONE!
Without her hubby. Awwwww.
Hi, Delores!
Hiiiiii. 'Kay, let's try this again, shall we?
What the fuck is that?
What the fuck is on the floor?
What is on the floor there? That's so cool.
Oh probably- well, we don't need bullets that's for sure.
Oh well, we got it anyway. Well, we got- okay, we don't need any of this.
This is not what we needed.
*Markimoo noise* Oh, fucking, fucking fuck!
Well I broke the game, weelll I broke the game, well I broke the fucking game.
Oh, boy. Weellll good to know.
Okayokayokay, gotta get that, gotta get that, gotta get the board.
Gotta get the cards, gotta get the wife, gotta get the wife... where's the wife, where's the wife at?
Where's that wifey-woo?
Where's that wifey of mine? There she is.
Okay, gotta get one more bottle of water, gotta get a lot of water.
We need to hydrate for all that we're gonna be doing.
Then we need to find the lock, wherever the hell that is.
Got the flashlight right here.
Where the hell's the lock, the hell's the lock, where the hell's the lock, where the hell's the lock?
Where's the goddamn lock?! I don't see the lock! I don't see the lock anywhere; where's the goddamn lock?
Don't fuck on- aaahhh there it is!
Woop, okay, we're outta here! Bye kids! Have fun in the nuclear apocalypse; we're outta here.
Woohoo! Not even close!
Not even close!
Done, baby! Oh, we're gonna have a good time.
Oh, we're gonna have a REAL good time.
Just me and the missus.
Hell yeah. Oh, that's lovely.
That's lovely. Not gonna help us in the nuclear winter
but that's lovely, eheeheehee.
Okay, so those are the only two challenges
available, but I know that's not why you're here.
And you guys know that's not why I'm here.
There was an update, yes.
But, it's also an excuse for me to try
ONE MORE TIME,
so that I maybe, just maybe, JUST MAYBE,
just maybe have what I need.
Okay? I'm not gonna try on Little Boy,
I'm trying on Fat Man. I have everything that I need.
It's gonna be okay. Right? It's gonna be okay, it's gonna be alright.
It's gonna be wonderful, we're gonna have good stuff happening.
One last try in this. One last, FINAL try to beat this fucking game.
So I just gotta get everything, get in the goddamn shelter,
let not everything die, and then everything's gonna be A-okay.
Gogogogo getgetget!
Clickity-clackety-clickity!
*growling*
Kadooshky.
Kadooshky- alright, get that.
Get the brief case, get the gas mask.
Gaaaaabooshky.
Okay, get this in here, get the map.
Get this.
Get that.
Did it-? Okay, goooooodoosky.
Okay, doing good, doing good. Gotta get the family,
gotta get the family. Can't get
family when she's there. Gotta get that and the radio.
Heepp. Okay gotta get the- *Markimoo noises*
We got thirty seconds left! Okay, gogogogogo, get you.
'Kay, might as well get you.
Get going, going, going, going, gone, gone, gone, gone.
Gogogo, get Timmy, get Timmy, get Timmy, get Timmy, get Tommy.
Ohhhh fuck, cutting it close, cutting it close. We do not
have a lot of food, I gotta make a food run.
Ohh, I can make it, I can make it. One more run.
One more run, one more run, one more run.
Food run, food run. Give, give, give, give, give, give, give, give.
Okay, here we go, here we go, here we go.
Do we have time for anything else? No I do not, let's go in!
Wahhhh, get in!
Get in!
Get in! Whooo! Okay. Hehhh, boy.
We got a lot of stuff. I think we got just about everything.
I'm not sure what.
I'm not sure what we got, but I think we got just about everything.
This is probably the best bet for us to be able to get through this.
We got a lot. Got a lot, mind you. We got a lot.
Huhh, we got bullets. Okay, we got bullets out of the suitcase,
so that's good, because I did grab the gun.
We got one more water, and we got everyone here.
So, I am going- I forget. Do you need to ration
the supplies immediately?
Do you need to ration the supplies right away?
It's every four days, I believe? No, it's not every four days,
because I forgot the boy scout hand book.
*gasp* Shhiitt, I'm a dick idiot!
I'm a dickiot! I'm an idiot!
That was the one thing I have to have!
Ohh no. Oh no, I forgot that.
Oh no, oh no, oh no, oohhhh NOOO!
"The boyscout handbook is arguably the most important
item in the shelter, as it has many - different - uses."
I fucked
up
really, really badly.
Ohh no. Okay.
Well, I fucked up really badly.
*singing* SOOO that is really bad!
I am dumb. I am dumb.
I am really fucking dumb.
Didn't do very good. *stops singing*
Ohh boy
"We can make it work, even in Toronto."
"Question is, how do we find a boat to get there?"
"We heard it's the best way to get to Europe."
What?
What?!
What the fuck is he talking about here?
Well, alright.
Let's prepare for an expedition.
Radio chair? Oh.
All those taxes, shall we head out?
Oh! Air drops!
Yes! Give us a boy scout handbook!
A BOY SCOUT HANDBOOK!
Nahh we just got supplies.
So we're gonna give everyone what they need. No.
Yeah. I think without the handbook
it's every three days,
but, maybe it's not anymore
because I did not see that in here.
It looks fine. Everyone's fine!
Everyone is okay!
Everyone's fine.
You go out there with a gas mask,
you have a good time.
Go get 'em buddy.
Go get 'em Teddy boy.
Wait, I forget. Is Ted the best one to go out?
Oh no, not-
Oh no.
Timmy is!
Timmy's the best scavenger.
But Timmy doesn't have the handbook,
so I don't know if that'd be good.
Okay. Could have sworn we had a huge puddle of water.
Ohh God!
A flood!
A flooood?
Well, we need the radio.
God dammit. Oh boy.
We are not having a good time here.
This is about the worst thing we could possibly imagine.
Radio is rescued but the map is...
deaaad.
Regular family has arguments but
it was never as intense as the fight we just got into.
No one wants to speak to each other.
Lets hope this won't last too long.
You know what's gonna help everybody?
Hats.
Hats make everything better!
Don't it?
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Death...
is...
imminent
for us.
We are all going to die.
Uhh we can barely sleep after arguing.
Let's hope it won't happen again.
We always steered away from casinos,
gambling dens and the like,
so when a man came to our door
and told us he used to be a gambler
we were suspicious.
Nnoope!
We're not even gonna try that
because I don't wa- I don't have anything to do it
and I wouldn't do it anyway.
Hey! Teddy's back!
Teddy looks tired.
You fucked up the gas mask?
Fuck you dude.
Come on!
He didn't get anything.
Ted didn't get anything!
TED YOU IDIOT!
God dammit Ted.
"We had the most curious visitor today."
"One that was making galloping sounds."
Eauuhhhhh!
I don't have a map.
It got ruined in the
FUCKING FLOOD!
Why didn't we gather any of that water, huh?
Why didn't we get any of that water, huh?
Alright Timmy. You go outside.
You bring everything.
You bring absolutely everything.
Have fun.
Have fun Timmy. Go on.
Go on out there Timmy! Go on out there.
Go on out there.
This- this game's already fucked,
so you might as well fuck us over some more.
*exasperated* Aye aye aye.
"Every s- new smell attacks our noses."
"There isn't much we can miss,"
"so when a single brick"
"revealing a tight opening,"
"our senses were immediately invaded by a-"
"this terrible stench."
"We should probably check out that hole"
"and see what the source of that smell is."
If I recall...
it's bad.
How 'bout we don't do that?
How 'bout we don't.
You can get used to anything,
absolutely anything.
"We decided to ignore the hole,"
"the stench, and anything that might happen because of it."
"We've taken enough risks already."
"We ended up feeling a bit unwell,"
"and later on we heard something moving in the hole."
"A few hours after that, the smell was gone."
Easy as that.
"One minute was all fine the next we were at our throats."
"How did this happen?"
"This is insane."
"We need to f- get a grip on ourselves if we're gonna survive this."
"Let's just sleep on it."
Yeah. I know!
Everything is fucked!
And everyone hates each other.
I know!
I am aware of this.
"We could barely sleep after all that arguing."
"Let's hope this won't happen again."
Alright.
Let's give everyone their stuff.
Turn on the radio! Why not?
It couldn't hurt.
Oh man.
It's this game!
Like, I don't know what it is about this game,
but it hates me!
This game hates me!
I don't know why!
"We were able to get a weak signal and tap into the"
"government's emergency announcement service,"
"and guess what?"
"Great news!"
"Fallout outside is mostly gone"
"and it should be much safer to travel on the surface."
Where is Timmy?
Timmy should be back.
"If there's anyone who can rescue us from this hellish situation,"
"it's our government."
"You can badmouth them all you want, but that probably means"
"you're a naysayer or a commie."
So let's go...
talk to the government.
Timmy's dead isn't he?
Timmy's dead.
"We made contact!"
"Military is on the way."
"Someone's at the door."
Alright. Let's open it up.
Aye come on in, buddy!
Come on in!
Come on!
Ah, apparently it's nothing bad- uh oh.
"Turned out it was a nice mysterious fellow in a weird suit."
"He gave us some soup cans."
"Help us survive an extra couple days."
"Opening the hatch was a bit risky."
"It seems it could've gave us..."
"It seems it gave us some awful sickness."
Mary Jane is sick.
"Alarm!"
"A group of people outside and they don't seem friendly."
Ookaay, let's just lock the door.
You'd think it would have a built in lock already.
Oh!
Timmy!
It's about fucking time!
I know you're sick.
but honestly, who gives a shit?
Everyone's gonna die anyway.
Did you get anything?
"We were so afraid for Timmy, but he came back"
"and is safe with us now."
"We believe that our expedition to the wasteland"
"must have been followed by strangers."
"We should be more cautious."
"During our expedition we stumbled upon the ruins of a familiar building,"
"our local bank."
"You never know what you might find."
"We found four cans of soup,"
"and one can of water, and a padlock."
"And two cans of soup."
Lost the bug spray and the GOD DAMN SUITCASE!
*exasperated* Aye aye aye aye.
Mary Jane go answer the phooooone.
Okay, Dolores is gonna go out and search for supplies
with nothing on hand.
I doubt she's gonna survive.
At least the radiation is a little lower than it was.
"There's a group of bandits!"
"With a bit of luck we can show them we're not to be trifled with."
Okay. How 'bout you go fuck yourself?
Hoow 'bout you go get bang bang?
Bang bang!
Oh fuck, the gun exploded.
Uhh, "We won the battle,"
"the bandits were no match for us."
Ah boy.
We got nothing to show for it.
Absolutely dick diddly to show for it.
Greeaat.
Woohoohoo.
Trash can's becoming bad.
Ohhh boy.
Giant roaches.
Wonderful!
Wooonderful!
Fucking wonderful!
Oh hello friend. How ya doin' down there?
How ya doin' friend? How ya doin'?
Timmy got back. Turned out his hand was infected.
Did- not healing up.
Oh god, cutting it off.
Fiiine! This better heal the rest of him too.
This better make him not sick.
Okay, he's better at least.
Oh, come on!
More bandits?
We just took care of them.
Could we throw our bullets at 'em?
Somebody should really sort them out.
Echh.
Ahhh!
Alright, we'll signal their plane.
Alright. Okay.
Fubwowski!
Fubooski!
Just don't fucking break it.
Oh hi Dolores. What'd you bring back?
Nothing of value. Great!
"Everything was going as planned but then the flashlight"
"stopped working."
"We were lucky to get it fixed"
"just in time to hear the distant roar of the plane's engines."
"We're pretty sure the pilot saw us"
"Let's see if they get back to us."
Okay!
"The silent wasteland had at least one resident who managed quite well."
"It was a proud looking monkey."
"We had no idea where it came from."
"The zoo..."
"maybe."
"It seemed very friendly."
"After getting a few pats on the back and playing fetch it started following us."
"While we explored one of the streets,"
"our monkey companion ran away,"
"only to come back later carrying a can of food."
"Couldn't open it himself but he was happy to share with us."
"At one point during our expedition,"
"the monkey started making weird sounds"
"and digging in front of us with a stick."
"A quick investigation revealed"
"a few bottles of water."
"No one even tried to open them."
"The same couldn't be said about those bottles"
"of booze lying next to them."
Well, that's good!
Yay, okay so now everyone needs...
everything
Beep beep dee boop.
Okay, good job everybody. You suck,
but I hate you.
"We always wanted a pet."
"No matter how, we have our very own cockroach now."
"Wanna teach them- we want them to teach and stay- play fetch."
God dammit.
Nope. We're just gonna be swimming in bugs,
and if- if- if
they become the cockroaches that
you can talk to,
and I don't have the fucking boy scout handbook to talk to them,
I'm going to be unbelievably pissed.
Unbelievably pissed.
"Our new cockroach roommates can be"
"a bit messy, disgusting, and annoying,"
"but surely this is not the worst that could've happened to us."
"There's not much we can do about it anyway."
"Maybe one day we'll convince them to pay rent."
Whooo's gonna go outside?
Absolute- whyyy is Timmy sick again?
You know what? Fuck it. No one's going outside.
We're gonna ride this one out.
We're just gonna riiide it out,
and everything's fine.
Timmy's sick a-fucking-gain.
"Found an anonymous note."
"Whoever wrote it requests that we send one representative"
"to a meeting tonight at a set location."
"That person must become unarmed."
"This worries us but the author assures he or she is friendly"
"and doesn't mean to hurt us."
"Are we going to send someone to check it out?"
Mmmmm...
*Markimoo noises* I don't knooow.
Seems bad.
I forget if this is good or bad.
I honestly have no idea.
I can't remember.
Nahh let's not do that.
We're not gonna do that.
Not gonna do that.
Nahh we don't need to send anybody.
Not that we need anybody here.
"This whole thing sounds too risky."
"We have no way of knowing wha- who left that letter."
"It might be a harmless prank or it might be a bandit trap."
"Either way we're staying put"
"and waiting for the army to come."
They have never once come for me.
Actually, they have.
They've once come for me and it was...
to lock me in and just trap me.
"Roaches seem to get more organized,"
"we have to deal with them before their civilization becomes"
"superior to ours."
No! We're not gonna do that.
We're gonna become infested with roach.
Were literally only gonna become roach.
"Our time will come, but for the time being we'll have to"
"adapt to this living situation. They're here, we're here."
"Let's make the best of it. They're only cockroaches, after all."
Yeah, we're not gonna do it- oh. "All hands on deck. There are people on the other side of the door and they don't seem friendly."
Ah, "They promised us a painful death"
"at least seventeen times today,"
"and it's only been five minutes since they arrived."
"We'd better prepare, they'll be forcing that door open."
Okay, lock! Good thing I got that!
Because otherwise they just come in and sweep through absolutely fucking everything.
WHAT?!
"When Mary Jane's sickness got worse and when we weren't able to provide her with medicine,"
"she deci- decided to cure whatever she had on her own."
"She left, saying she's not coming back."
"We were able to fight off the bandits this time,"
"but there's no guarantee they won't come back. We will need to be prepared at all times."
That's not gonna happen at all.
Ho, boy.
Well, this is going poorly.
Is that a-? Wait.
Wh- is that a drawing of a lady?
Is that a drawing of a lady with a boot?
Is that literally a drawing of a lady with a boot or a lady with an axe?
I'm not a hundred percent sure.
Or a lady strangling a penguin.
Ahh, boy.
Nope!
Nope, cockroaches are just gonna be here, forever.
That's- that's what we do.
That's how we do it.
That's what we- okay, everyone's sick.
Great! Everyone's sick.
*strained laughter* Wonderful! Wonderful!
"Although they're a bit glowy, and we're pretty sure they spread diseases, we have no means of fighting those damn roaches."
"Best get used to the situation. Better the roaches than bandits. Or commies."
NOOOOOOOOOOO!!
Oh, god, "A band of raiders are at our doorstep, we either yield or fight back, there's no middle ground here!"
Oh noooooo!!
Oh NOOOOOO!!
NOOOOOOOOOOOOOO!!!
Oh...
Did they take Timmy?
"We watched helplessly as those cruel thugs took Timmy out of the shelter..."
*strained laughter* "We hope we'll see him again someday."
Oh no. Oh no.
Oh, no.
Ohhh, no, the bandits are sssooo horrendous.
"Military communication is through the radio, we're sure... it was signal to evacuate out of here, but turns they need our help."
"Need chop down a tree or two."
I can't DO that!
I don't have what I NEED!
I don't HAVE that!
Just KILL me!
End this torment!
End it!
Ohhhhhh, just end it!
THE RAIDERS ARE BACK!
OH NOOOO!
OOHHHHH, THEY TOOK DOLORES!
OH, GODDAMMIT, THEY TOOK DOLORES!
Ah, fuck.
Welp... that's not good.
I DID show 'em a show of force!
*sniffle*
Then my thing blew up!
Well, plenty of food and water for him.
Oh, no, it's the letter!
I don't think- I don't think so!
If I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die alone in my shelter without my family.
Oh, boy. Welp.
Bandits are at the door again.
Of course they're at the door again.
Why wouldn't they-? I'm- yup.
I'm fucking dead, they shot me in my face.
Good fucking god. *frustrated laughter*
"We thought these bandits would just kill us all, but instead they grabbed Ted and took him away at gunpoint."
"We hope nothing bad happened to him."
Well technically, maybe I'm not dead!
Maybe I just got sold as a slave!
That's great!
Aw, fuck.
*loud groaning into hands*
Welp! That went about as much as I expected it to be.
I... can't win at this one.
No matter how good I think I'm going, no matter how well I think I'm doing,
I will always fail.
And that is just the life that I live in this game.
But either way!
Thank you all so much for watching.
I don't think I'm ever gonna win at this game.
But there's more DLC on the way, so maybe I'll try it again when that new DLC comes out.
But until then...
I am left to my own devices, and I am left alone and scared with all my family members being grabbed up by BANDITS!
So thank you, again, everybody for watching,
and if you got any tips or tricks for me,
write 'em down in the comments below.
So thanks again, and as always,
I will see you... in the next video.
Buh-byeee!
[Outro Music Plays at Full]